the pre-move skill
yeah like crazy tactics i'm out here
like yo this man's 1800 what am i losing
to him
what
all right okay so best of three bullet
okay reverse to two no speed chest
championship bullet like just one oh
it almost got me free moving over the
board
i'm not gonna hang another queen
although youtube doesn't know about the
other games
you don't want to take my people
looks like i'm in the driver's seat the
game is over
and then i hang my queen in one move
what am i doing it's just a free queen
and i'm like let's see my heart rate any
it's just hanging he can just queen to
oh my god he doesn't see it
tactics look different over the board
what is going on here you tell me
some
tension here among pieces
what
this pawn takes night yeah what are we
doing
at least the file's open now yeah you're
right
yeah i had a feeling the game the game
was never over
um
now i'm scared
i didn't expect to even get this far
what
go away
uh
[Music]
you
lost
it's so close to stalemate too i know
but my pawn is so far away from the
clock
well let's see what let's see what my
heart rate is after that one 104
double my wrestling nice very good
okay yeah i'm ready
this is very interesting position
this is like soviet championship or
something
it's simply fine
please
um i don't like my position
i gave you too much like happiness in
this position
i played it i was like he could take it
and then he took it
that's a problem
no it's not it's not a problem because
you have that move that's crazy
i faked you i'm sorry
i almost played anyways
[Music]
yeah
that was crazy man i was like oh he can
go straight down queens can also go like
that
oh we're doing best of three right
should we do a
uh
tiebreaker
i hung a queen and mate today
is this it this is the last game and
you're going to go
one more blitz game uh i probably got it
wrong all right
this is it this is the final game until
if i win this game you can't come back
to new york city do you win this game
i'll give you my shirts
no don't do that no you're gonna like
that's
gotta true it on a good note
ah this one
what's this one
eric leave me alone
how did this happen
i'm scared
[Music]
yeah but like so
no it's this is this is this is really
bad it is
oh my god
i have no moves
i just have to lose all my pieces
it's not like a crazy thing that i'm
all right eric okay you can come back to
new york city
wow um that's not making it in the video
i hope um hello to youtube
hello everyone here
there's no one here we just it's here
it's like uh
8 in the morning and it's all green
screen and
that might have been the worst game i've
ever played so that was pretty bad yeah